حاله كبيره من الجدل اثارها مسلسل دراما
المصري ازمه منتصف العمر الذي يتصدر
المشاهدات في العديد من الدول قصه العمل
تتحدث عن شاب يتزوج من فتاه وتجمعه في
التوقيت نفسه علاقه بزوجه ابيها اثارت
بلبل وضجه كبيره بسبب العلاقات بين ابطال
المسلسل والتي وصفت بانها الدراما شرارتها
الخطيئه البشريه تهدد قيم الاسر ورغم ذلك
الى ان صناع العمل اكدوا ان المسلسل ماخوذ
عن قصه حقيقيه وقعت بالفعل محاولات تخفيف
الصدمه في العمل بان جعلوا البطل يقع في
غرام زوجه الاب لكن ما حدث في الحقيقه هو
وجود علاقه تجمع بين البطل ووالده زوجته
مسلسل ازمه منتصف العمر بطوله مسلسل ازمه
منتصف العمر بطوله كريم فهمي ريهام عبد
الغفور عمر سعيد رنا رئيس واخراج كريم
العدل
[موسيقى]
مبسوط انت كل شويه قاعدين بنتقابل كده
مش عايز تروحي اعمل لك ايه
[موسيقى]
مبروك يا عروسه
تفهمي ايه انت عشان تروحي تكلميني بتفهمي
ايه
انا العياده الصغيره اللي انت رحت
اتجوزتها
حاسه اني بحلم
حاسه ان انا متجوزه واحد معروفوش عملت لك
ايه
[موسيقى]
من فيسبوك من الكوميكس اللي اتعملت على
المسلسل وبتاع امه وبنتها حامل من نفس
الشخص ومش عارف ايه هو يعني الموضوع مش
لطيف الصراحه يعني المس فكرته غير الكاتشر
بتاعتنا ممكن يطبق بره في امريكا انما
عندنا هنا في مصر ده غير تماما الديانه
بتاعتنا وغير ثقافه المجتمع بتاعنا مسلسل
مبني على فكره بناء مهمه جدا وهي انك لازم
تبقى عارف انت بتعمل ايه قبل ما تعمله
والسبب انك تفهم المفروض تناسب العائلات
والمفروض تفهم العائلات بتتكلم عن ايه
والكلام دوت او يستحق الجدول فني
حاجه جربها وكله عشان هي اكيد يعني عك
كتير بيحصل في المسلسل ما كل الجدل عليها
اه يعني لازم يحصل اصلا
انا بالنسبه لي الموضوع مش مؤثر عليا يعني
عشان هو انا مش باخد المسلسلات بصوره
شخصيه فخلاص يعني لو مش عاجبني ما اتفرجش
مش لازم اعمل حوار يعني زي اي حاجه بتحصل
على فكره في الواقع اللي انت عايش فيه
حاجه بتحصل من كده واصعب من كده وكمان هو
بقى طلع لك في المسلسل ان ده اصلا ملهوش
يعني مش امها الحقيقيه فانا مش شايفه ان
في حاجه عشان كل ده يحصل يعني عادي فكره
ان الواحد يتجوز بنت وامها وان الاثنين
يحملوا منه فاللي هو العلاقات الاسريه
باظت بس يعني لا هو يستحق البروجانده اللي
طلعت عليه بصراحه
[موسيقى]
على كل من القاهره ينضم الينا احمد عادل
سلطان مؤلف مسلسل ازمه منتصف العمر وينضم
الينا كذلك النقد الفني احمد سعد الدين
اهلا بكما ابدا معك سيد احمد انتم كمؤلف
لهذا المسلسل بالانتقادات التي وجهت له
يعني التمثيل جيد جدا لكن الانتقادات كانت
حول جراه المشاهد وفكره المسلسل تفضل
هو فعلا المسلسل الجريء شويه هو مبدئيا
احمد عادل سلطان
حضرتك سمعاني
كيف ترد على من انتقدوا المسلسل
انا متفهم جدا فكره النقد متفهم جدا فكره
ان الموضوع جريء بس في نقد انا متفهمه جدا
وفي نقض تاني من باب ان حاجه جديده اتقدمت
فبنقدها
وبحس ان في نقد برضو جاي على الصوره
العامه للمسلسل كله ماشي ورا ان فكره
المسلسل بيناقش قضيه زينه المحارم زينه
المحارم فبحس ان في ناس اصلا ما شافتش
المسلسل وبتنقض
طيب طالما هاي النقطه هي اللي عمالكم
بتعملوها كنقطه الدفاع اليوم احمد سعد
الدين انا ساحكي بالعيله عشان نفرق بين
الاحمدين احمد سعد الدين اليوم لما يكون
عندك في قصص في الحياه اصلا موجوده هي عكس
الطبيعه وبتهون حالات فرديه مش حالات عامه
ما المانع انه يتم تصويرها بقالب درامي
تشويقي للمشاهد
صباح الخير عليك وصباح الخير على ضيفك
الكريم هو قبل ما نقول كده نقول ايه الهدف
اساسا من وجود الدراما التلفزيونيه
الدراما التلفزيونيه قائمه على ثلاث اضلاع
مهمه جدا منها تثقيف منها توعيه منها
ترفيه الاساس في الدراما التليفزيونيه في
كل مجتمع هي اولا لابد ان تراعي محددات
وعادات وتقاليد هذا المجتمع كل المجتمعات
بيحصل فيها حوادث وبيحصل فيها مشاكل
وبيحصل فيها خروج على المالوف وعلى
القانون ده طبيعي ممكن يكون المسلسل نفسه
متاخد عن قصه حقيقيه ولكن السؤال الاهم هل
الدراما تنقل الواقع ولا هي انعكاس للواقع
لو تنقل الواقع طب ما احنا كل يوم بنشوف
حوادث فممكن الحوادث دي لا تصلح دراميه
لكن في نفس الوقت لازم ابقى فاهم كويس جدا
ان انا هذه الدراما بتدخل البيوت حتى لو
كانت على المنصات بتدخل البيوت في مجتمعات
الاميه بتبقى نسبه كبيره جدا منها بيحصل
مشكله ما بين الواقع
والحقيقه او الواقع والفن الموجود هنا
بيحصل اللخبطه هل الدراما بقى بتفكك
الاسره في الوقت ده بتدي نماذج حتى لو ما
قلتش تفكيك اسري ولكن تدي نماذج خارج على
المالوف ولا المفروض ان هي يعني تتماشى مع
وقع معين احنا كنا بنشوف جزء من هذا
الشكل الموجود في المسلسل بشكل بسيط جدا
في بعض الاعمال سواء كانت دراما او كانت
سينما بنلاقيه خط على جنب لكن المسلسل
بالكامل قائم على الخارجين عن المالوف هي
دي مشكله المسلسل في الوقت الحالي طيب
عادل سلطان يعني في ناس ما شافوا المسلسل
وانتقدوه طيب كان في التعليقات لناس شافوا
حلقات المسلسل كلها بيقولوا المسلسل جامد
من حيث التمثيل واداء الممثلين لكن فكره
المسلسل كلها غلط وخالف قيم المجتمع
المصري وتؤثر على المجتمع سلبا ولا تصلح
دراميا كيف تردون على ذلك
[موسيقى]
ايه بالظبط المس
لسل واي فكره في العالم تصلح دراميه لو
بتتناول بشكل سليم
فانا مش عارف انهي فكره بالزبط اللي لا
تصلح انها يعني تتناقش دراميا فكره
المسلسل في المطلق
فكره ان يقع زوج الابنه في حب حماته فكره
المسلسل كلها
ايوه لا هو في ناس شايفه دي فكره المسلسل
والفكره الاساسيه للمسلسل هي فكره جواز
البنات في سن صغير بيحصل له ايه هو لو ما
كانتش حماتي لو كانت اي حد تاني في السن
ده كان هيغلط نفس الغلطه دي
المسلسل لو عايزه تلخصي فكره المسلسل
العامه اللي انا كنت عايز اناقشها في
الكتابه فكره ان
اي بنت اي بنت بتتجوز في السن الصغير ده
لازم يحصل الخلل ده في السن
الكبير حضرتك معايا اتفضل
فهو هو دي هي دي المشكله الاساسيه بالنسبه
يعني القضيه العامه اللي انا كنت قاصد
اناقشها في المسلسل فكره تفاوت الاعمار في
الزواج بينتج نتيجته ايه انما فكره
الولد اللي وقع في حد في حب حماته يعني
الموضوع ده متواجد بشكل انا ما بقولش ان
هو متواجد بشكل كبير في المجتمع بتاعنا او
بقول ان دي حاجه صح او بقول ان دي حاجه
وارد ان هي تحصل بس انا بتكلم على خيال
الدرامي وصلني ان ماذا لو العمرين يعني
اللي هم اللي هم يصلحوا لبعض من الاساس
كاعمار
اتحطوا في نفس الموقف ده هيحصل ايه
فحصل اللي حصل يعني طيب احمد سعد الدين
كيف تردون على احمد يعني هل بالفعل اي قصه
حقيقيه تصلح لان تكون قصه دراميه
اي قصه ممكن تصلح ان تكون قصه دراميه
طالما تمتلك الخيوط الاساسيه لكن هنا
الفارق في ايه ما يصلح في الغرب قد لا
يصلح على المجتمعات او داخل المجتمعات
الشرقيه ليه لان برغم ان كل الجرائم
موجوده في المجتمعات الشرقيه ولكن في نفس
الوقت هذا المسلسل لو انا عرضته على
مجموعه من النخبه هيبقى كويس جدا
وهيتفهموا الخطوط الرئيسيه للمسلسل
والزواج البنات المبكر اوكي لكن لما باجي
في المجتمعات غير المثقفه وغير المتعلمه
واللي فيها اميه وهنا القاعده العريضه هل
يستطيع ان يفرق ما بين
الخطوط الاساسيه وما بين اللي هو شايفه
وشايف العلاقه ما بين
زوج وحماته اللي اتفك اللغز بعد اربع خمس
حلقات يعني اخد ساسبينس فتره من الزمن ما
يقرب من ساعه ونص او ساعتين وهنا اسال
نفسي واسال المؤلف واسال كل الناس هل اضمن
اللي اللي شاف الحلقه الاولى والتانيه هو
اللي يكمل باقي الحلقات بالتاكيد هناك
تفاوت ممكن القصه دي تصلح في السينما تصلح
في السينما ليه لان السينما واحده واحده
مده كده من ساعه ونصف لساعتين من اولها
لاخرها المشاهد قاعد بيشوف الدنيا رايحه
فين وفي النهايه بيعرف الايه الحقيقه
ماشيه ازاي لكن في المسلسل على مدار 13
حلقه 13 حلقه انا مش ضامن كل الناس تتفرج
على ال13 حلقه في نفس الوقت المجتمع
الموجود احنا مش اوصيان بس في نفس الوقت
بنقول والله يا جماعه مستوى المجتمع ده ما
يصلح مع عندي طبقه نقطه نخبه وعندي طبقه
وسط وطبقه شعبيه ما يصلح لهذه الطبقات ايه
هي دي مشكله احنا ليه دائما لما على
الدراما نرجع لقلق الحجميه من 35 سنه
لانها قدرت ان هي توصل وتنقل المجتمعات
والعادات والتقاليد حتى لو كان فيها خروج
ما هو سليم البدري كان رجل مزواج
فقط سعد الدين احمد عادل يرد هل خلال
تاليفكم لهذا المسلسل من خلال جرته كنتم
تستهدفون استقطاب فضول المشاهد واثاره هذا
الجدل
انا بس عندي تعليق بسيط اني لقى المشاهد
بتاعنا على درايه كامله بالعالم انا لما
اي مسلسل
سوري اي مسلسل اجنبي بينزل سواء ولا كذا
ولا اي حاجه في العالم بتنزل على اي بلاد
فورمه موجوده في الوطن العربي بتاعنا هي
بتبقى جوه الوطن العربي ده اكبر دليل ان
الوطن العربي بتاعنا بيشوف كل حاجه في
العالم هو مش مش مجتمع منغلق او او مش
متفتح او مش فاهم ايه اللي بيحصل ولو انا
مشيت ولا ولا مدرسه ان انا لازم اقدم
حاجات تتناسب مع العقليه البسيطه جدا
للمجتمع انا هرجع بالدرامه لورا جدا يعني
هبتدي فعلا ارجع تاني ليالي الحلميه وكده
وعمري ما هتقدم بالدراما انما انا شايف ان
مجتمعاتنا بتتطور بشكل ملحوظ جدا وعندها
العقل الكافي ان هي تتقبل اي فكره نتيجه
احمد عادل سلطان
انا قد الفني احمد سعد الدين